so this slow training is just moving
from control point to control point
um without uh
in this case using the inertia or the
momentum of the person
to have that be my control point this is
going to teach you
more um it's going to bring more of the
internal aspects
into it uh but also even better
understanding of just
the anatomy of the human being and their
their
basic support structure and all that
kind of stuff okay so
it's important that he's he's he's got
some energy
and i'm going really slow slow slow slow
slow slow
and i am going to keep working these
things
in a way that um so let's say he
if he were to resist resist resist
resist
it just works in the conducive you see
so
that i have control and then i'm gonna
do it in a way
everything in a way that try not to fall
try not to fall and he
has to fall oh
full control control
control
[Music]
so
okay so um
the contrast between external aspects
and internal aspects
are are only in a way oppositional from
a learning point of view view but from
an application point of view they're not
okay you and this drill is a way that
you use uh your your coq or your ip
and making sure that it's free of any
kind of momentum and inertia which of
course you would use
but you will have a much more solid
mechanical understanding
of the deconstruction of their partial
ability let's just say kazushi
if you solve for
tokyo nike without inertia momentum that
kind of stuff okay
so i am using koku and nike but i'm
using it in a way
that i'm venturing into the mechanical
uh application of what am i doing to his
body mechanically and hence
it's not oppositional to external things
okay
so uh as as we go i'll
we'll show you how this works okay so um
he came in and here's your jiu jitsu
yield all right
but uh let's let's change him
he wants to push on me and he's not
going to push because
everything is grounded on the back foot
everything's grounded on the back foot
okay and then um when we turn
at this hand this hand sword on on the
back side
uh is ready for him if he tries to pull
out
so he pulls out and i have that energy
there okay
so we're in this lock now as i'm doing
this stuff
okay and um let's say he tries to lift
his leg the downward energy here he
can't lose his leg
okay uh let's say he uh
tries to let go here and you'll have the
ik adhesion or let's say he tries to
strike me
you'll have the inside line and the same
thing goes on here
uh you'll have the inside line um he
tries to let go
you still have your own grip so you're
in you're in a mechanical
position of control okay and as you move
you should
be doing the same stuff so as i'm about
to
uh enter i'm going to bring him around
in a way that you're just making all of
that all of that
worse okay so again let's say he
tries to let go on the top hand you're
going to have the inside hand
and he let's go on the top hands like
chess you're going to set up the dilemma
of the demon
because you're on the inside so
everything is working that way
now i don't want him turning either so
let's say he tries to turn then he's not
going to turn
he goes into his base he tries to turn
the other way he's not going to do it
and of course you have the same dilemma
so he uh he turns he's turning this way
he turns that way you're going to set up
the advantage
he turns the other way right you're
going to set up the other hand
into the rear body so you're setting up
these energetic dilemmas okay
and now as i move around i'm going to
add another
control point at his neck okay
and it's the same thing so if he uh
let's go you still have the arm if he
lets go
you still have the arm and but you now
have a more direct control of his center
line through his spine so you should use
it you should not be going around this
i make that adhesion point and i use
that
to keep the head where it is as the
hands and the weight shift can continue
to bring it forward
and he's more into the tilt okay so
again
if he lets go it's almost irrelevant
it's going to be
in space that i can use to hinder do it
again it's going to let me
enter if he let's go on the other hand
the head is already under control i made
that
hand redundant with the head control all
right now
let's just say uh he just resists and
taps
well it all goes into the same ground
victory
and then as i come into the throw
i do the throw i'm not going to use
momentum and take him out
[Music]
i'm going to structurally
vector in a way that
he's being deconstructed posturally okay
so resist
and i want to carry that idea
all all the way through so even when i
get to the end
i don't go momentum
i keep uh pressuring his center
so i'm here and i look for the hip lock
now
the hip lock and the headlock and that's
what does the throat
so i have a mechanical control the
entire time
boom
same even on enikio not out here where
it's handsome
so boom i gotta get to the inside
inside so he let's go
i'm on the inside
he tries to push and grab a factory he
tries to pull it just feeds the detail
okay and then same thing don't tilt him
over himself
keep structurally compressing
post until it's deconstructed
quite hand around
pull no push
no it's not gonna work but then don't go
momentum at this
rate mechanically make sure your throw
is happening
so resist
okay try try to make it where you take
out all the inertial momentum
okay